you know uh i did uh yeah i grew up in
the south in mississippi and you know
you just grew up with those family
values and i came from a very small town
so you always dreamt of what your future
family would look like and
now that i'm able to you know to have
kids and build that family that i always
wanted
it's it's a dream come true i've been
able to spend pretty much every single
day with them of their life and that is
just a true blessing you have been
married to your very handsome husband
michael for many years now queer love is
real it's out there and it's never going
away
no no we're just more visible now which
is so great did you actually ever have a
point in your life where you thought
maybe none of this would ever happen for
you having a husband having kids i mean
once i was able to come out and be
myself
i really did feel that kids were not in
the stars for me i mean we had so much
opposition from everything we did we
were fighting for marriage equality so
kids were kind of the last thing i was
thinking of and you know you get told so
many times you're not supposed to have
kids that you start to believe it in a
way
eventually you kind of come out of that
and say no i need to be living the life
i want to live and you know screw
everyone else
that's the tea that is the tea lanthan i
love it how does it feel to be somebody
that queer people feel represented by
just being yourself is so powerful and i
think you know if you're in the public
eye
you know you have a responsibility
especially as an lgbtqia person you know
you want to be a good representation and
now there's all flavors of the rainbow
you know being represented and doing
super great things in this entertainment
industry from musicians to actors i mean
there's just incredible a-list lgbt
artist right now and
it's so
crazy that that's only happened in the
last 10 years and so i cannot imagine
what is going to happen the next 10
years it is going to
i mean the whole industry is going to be
fabulous
[Music]